[موسيقى]
افتتاح ساحه جديده للحرب والجيش البولندي
يعد الغده بانتظار ساعه صفر والبحر الاسود
يشتعل وبوتين يطمئن العالم سنصدر القمح
حتى بالمجان ولكن وفق شروطنا فماذا لم تتم
الاستجابه للشروط الروسيه هل يربط العالم
على بطنه بالحجاره وسلاح روسي جعل
الاوكرانيين في صدمه من العجز واشنطن
تفتتح مخازن اسلحتها مجددا والاتحاد
الاوروبي يفتح احضانه لتركيا والعراق يوجه
صفعه قويه للسويد بينما السعوديه تستنكر
التصرفات السويديه هذا اقصى ما تستطيع
فعله قبله المسلمين ويل ماسك يخسر عشرين
مليار دولار في يوم واحد فكيف ذلك وامريكا
ترسل قوات المارينز الى مياه الخليج والف
جندي اسرائيلي يعلقون اسلحتهم
وعيد البحر الاسود
كل تلك المعارك في اوكرانيا تطفو على
السطح حرب من نوع اخر حرب اخضاع الخصم او
الخضوع ولا خيار اخر فنحن امام حرب البطون
الخاويه ليستمر هنا الوعيد المتبادل بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا وبعد ان كانت روسيا قد
اعلنت قبل ايام ان اي سفينه مبحره بالبحر
الاسود سيتم اعتبارها هدفا عسكريا مشروعا
حتى ان واشنطن اعلنت انها لن تغامر بخرق
هذا التهديد الروسي لكن الدوره جاء هذه
المره على اوكرانيا والتي اعلنت انها
ستعامل السفن المنتجه الى روسيا في البحر
الاسود بالمثل اي انها ستستهدف سفن روسيا
وحلفائها في البحر الاسود الوعد يزداد في
البحر الاسود يا ساده فهل من اتفاق اخر
لامداد العالم بالحبوب اما بالنسبه لروسيا
فان لم يكفي الوعيد فهنا رساله من نوع اخر
[موسيقى]
البحر الاسود الروسي بالصواريخ المجنحه
بانها تحذير شديد اللهجه من الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين الى زينينسكي من ان السفن
التي تحمل امدادات لاوكرانيا ستكون اهداف
مشروعه اذا فهي حرب الغذاء بين الطرفين
ولا شيء اخر مهلا مهلا فلم ينتهي كل شيء
وهو بوتين يؤكد على استعداد بلاده لتعويض
الحبوب الاوكرانيه في السوق العالميه سواء
كان ذلك مجانا ام على اساس تجاري مضيفا ان
روسيا مستعده للعوده الى صفقه الحبوب اذا
تم تنفيذ جميع شروط المتفق عليها سابقا
لتعلنها سفاره موسكو في القاهره ان
السياسيين الغربيين يواصلون اتهام روسيا
بالانسحاب من صفقه حبوب البحر الاسود لكن
روسيا هي الدوله الوحيده في الصفقه التي
كانت تعمل من طرف واحد هل كانت كذلك
ومن حرب الغذاء ننتقل نحو المعارك الطاحنه
في اوكرانيا حيث قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين انه هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد
لم يحقق اي نتائج مع خساره كييف لعشرات
الالاف من الجنود مضيفا ان الغرب باسره
يرى ان معداتهم الفاخره تحترق تماما بل ان
المعدات السوفييتيه تتفوق عليها في بعض
النواحي رفقه تعبيره فيما قال المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
شنت هجوما جديدا على ورش لصناعه القوارب
المسيره في اوديسا جنوبيه اوكرانيا ليضيف
بان القوات الروسيه صدت 16 هجوما اوكرانيا
في محور شرقي البلاد في الجانب المقابل
قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
تواصل الهجوم في
مناطقون
تقدم الق الروسيه في اتجاه كوفيانس
كوليمان في مقاطاعتي خاركيف مشيرا الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه صدت جميع الهجمات
الروسيه هناك بينما اقر المتحدث باسم سلاح
الجو الاوكراني لان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
عاجزه عن صد صواريخ اونيكس الروسيه الاسرع
من الصوت التي يمكنها تدمير حامله طائرات
على مدى 600 كيلومتر فيا لها من قدرات
مخيفه وكيف لاوكرانيا ان توقف سلاحا كهذا
اذا اما الولايات المتحده فلا تكل ولا تمل
عن مد اوكرانيا بالدعم رغم كل تلك الخسائر
وها هي واشنطن تحضر للاعلان عن حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 400
مليون دولار مع ذلك في الاسبوع المقبل حسب
قناه سي ان ان كما تتضمن الحزمه الجديده
صواريخ اضافيه لانظمه الدفاع الجوي نيسانس
قصيره ومتوسطه
[موسيقى]
تعزيز وجوده شرق البلاد بسبب التحديات
الامنيه
مره اخرى على الرئيس الروسي بوتين محذرا
من عواقب اي عدوان على بيلاروسيا واعتبره
عدوانا على بلاده سيتم الرد عليه بكل سبل
المتاحه
الاحداث والتطورات
بسبب تكرار حرق القران العراق يشهر الكرت
الاحمر في وجه السويد وبعد ان قالها
السفير السويدي في بغداد نفكر بالنف
العراقي بديلا عن النفط الروسي في بدايه
الحرب الاوكرانيه والعراق اليوم يقول لا
نفط لكم ان بعد اليوم لتلغي بغداد جميع
اتفاقاتها الدوليه والتجاريه مع ستوكهولم
اما قبله المسلمين ونقصد السعوديه فقد
اكتفت بالتنديد وليسكم تاخذون من العراق
درسا يا هؤلاء قررت الولايات المتحده
ارسال سفن حربيه اضافيه وقوات من مشاه
البحريه المارينز الى الشرق الاوسط لتعزيز
الامن في مياه
ومواجهه ما تعتبره واشنطن انشطه ايران
المزعزعه للاستقرار مجموعه الاستعداد
البرمائيه
[موسيقى]
ستلتحق بالمدمر
التي ارسلت الاسبوع الماضي الى الخليج
اتفق وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي على
استئناف التواصل مع تركيا بخصوص انضمامها
للاتحاد لكنهم وضعوا بعض الشروط مشيرين
الى ان التكثر الاوروبي يريد من تركيا
ابداء مرونه ايضا على سيماف ما يتعلق
بقضيه قبرص العضو في الاتحاد خسر رجل
الاعمال والمليارديرو الامريكي قرابه 20
مليار دولار في يوم واحد اثراء هبوطي سامي
شركه السيارات الكهربائيه تسلا في البورصه
الامريكيه اعلن 1140 جنديا احتياطيا في
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي تعليق تطوعهم بالجيش
احتجاجا على خطط الحكومه لاصلاح النظام
الق ضائي
[موسيقى]